Chicago politics is ruthless okay I'm
telling you this is more about kim fox
in that situation than Jesse they're
just using Jesse as come on yeah it was
no victims that can't really prove it
and everything was this is really
happening
all the time and even if it was a hoax
for the sake of bringing attention to
this then I'm like that's low-key noble
like I'm just at my wit's end
about us centering situations like this
and wanting to make people have to pay
and it's like hot spot spot spot spot
spot you about to go in I'm telling you
she said low-key noble three two one I
need more time to process does she seem
low-key noble because she said she
brought up Emmett Till yeah Emmett Till
was in that situation because someone
made a hoax about him yeah
Jesse small a made a hoax that involved
two other black people what if those
other black people were apprehended by
the police and getting some kind of bad
situations I want she's saying it's
noble because the fact that she feels
like it brings attention what it
actually does is it makes people less
likely to believe Brian Wolfe because
now we're saying there's people who are
doing this for attention or doing this
for what F this is what I talk about
when I say this broad is fake whoa and I
didn't think I'd have to cover her but
she finds a way to say stuff that I'm
like are you serious
you think fake crimes is noble censoring
situations like this and wanting to make
people have to pay and it's like
puss puss puss we don't make people want
to pay the thing is if you commit a
crime you do the time you wasted police
resources you had people working around
the clock looking for pen you had a
whole city scared that this stuff was
potentially happening right you had a
whole world basically stoking up racial
tensions and you think the person who
did all this shouldn't have to pay Amber
Heard is not a hero she's she's not
noble because she faked what happened
and it does not bring light to what
happened if even after the fact she goes
and she goes in protest and room for she
is
not a hero I don't know how you guys
could take this person and say she has
integrity if she thinks lying and
deceiving everybody is noble what do you
think that she's doing in her own time
this young man and she announced that
she was lying about it they should have
put the shackles on her that day and
she's walking around so that was what
about ISM to his best so because in
Emmett Till's case the girl that liked
the woman that live is walking free then
Jesse should walk free the solution to
the fact that white get away with the
same private is black people it's not
for a black will to get away with them
it's for everyone who did commit those
to go to jail period that's what it is
what's your advocating for strict chaos
you want to let predators and all kinds
of people go free because the fact that
their white counterparts are getting
away with it your argument is so
unbelievably irresponsible to the fact
that you get to say it on national TV
and what more to have people clap as if
it's a good thing you know what they're
mad about their time their resources
being the money the taxpayers resources
taxpayers resources are being used every
day to imprison people who have done
nothing but being an addict people that
feel that well what if I'm really
happens to me and now because of what
Jesse said now they don't believe if
this is if this one instance is what
makes them not believe you baby that's a
lie that they're telling ourselves we
have lived in a nation where they don't
believe every day every single shot
Jesse is the like an it is huge
nationwide news because he is famous so
if it was a hoax what do you think is
the correct punishment cuz you said it
wears mostly no boy just literally
should be like he should be applauded
damn they got smacked on the wrist for
all these people
and they can't give a smack on the wrist
and Jesse Smollett like because they're
saying that it's a whole big thing I'm
just I don't believe it should we look
at black men who are constantly getting
the book thrown at them all the time all
the time
[Applause]
Wow
this bra digit bugging like sometimes
like a stance is so incredibly stupid
that I have to process in my head where
this person was trying to come from in
order to get to this place and and when
I do I'm just like do you not have any
self awareness like what are you saying
right now and she said it's an isolated
incident
let me be clear there's people who are
fake reporting on a regular basis it's
not an isolated incident this was just a
high-profile incident right everyone was
talking about it because everyone was
afraid people were running around with
nooses I'm just like we know that
misinformation is a bad thing we know
that misleading the public is a bad
thing but in this instance is okay why
so like I've been the victim of
literally just someone making up some
[ __ ] just so people will click so
they've made money off of lying about me
we live in an era where there's just a
wild obsession with creating conflict
versus quelling it yes keep the same
energy before they're not they're not
even they're not even God and I'm just
confused they're not consistent what
they think I'm genuinely confused
low-key well listen you know what if you
want to have that stance have that
stance but the next time a victim of a
Weinstein case is not believed and
people go why why why why well it's
because people like Amanda think it's
Noble to fake stuff it's noble to lie
it's noble to mislead people do you guys
thought you know chivalry was noble no
no lying I'm gonna cheat on my girl see
like why you cheat on me cuz it's Noble
why don't we need to be honest I've
never this made me take the cake I'm
Jamie since the shocker this noble you
you're off you're off right nobody it's
noble isn't it ironic that she says
lying is noble because it brings light
to a good comms yeah but she got mad at
Rodney Reed's legal team cuz she felt
like they were being misleading and I
think it is mostly important that when
you are presenting to the people things
this nature of this sensitivity of this
temerity I'm not sure if I use that word
in the right sense we have to have a
certain level of ethics then I remember
that video ashtag abba with the receipts
but didn't she say that Wow Abba with
the receipt you see now he's back I was
back with the receipts oh yes she was
right he's back now good to have you
back ever exactly so when she lied and
she said that Rodney Reed had murdered
someone who's still alive she was not
lying she was being noble yes but when
they did it when she felt that day today
it wasn't yeah so much she got kicked
out at that Emmy party right that black
every party and she said a white woman
kicked her out but it was actually just
the black woman she was being know he
was being noble because she was pinning
it on a white woman but it was Noble
and as a white woman telling me I can't
go in
a white woman is telling me I came and
it was a white one they mean Chiara
oh I'm starting to understand it all so
you're back now you got the receipts
everything is back I think it's fluid
this up and up right good thinking now
good to have you back I understand that
so she was a narcissist no no there you
go you put one in one thing okay okay
good of you you put one and one together
Thanks albums back with the noble noble
God he's back you got up there thinking
got receivers [ __ ] I chose talks about
how books March is Barney noble nutbar
even though it all connects it comes
back full circle Barnes and Noble's
she's lying she's noble they're not no
book I've walked if ISM we got it we
cracked the code bro
thank you for watching this episode of
the real you guys have a wonderful day
it's ironic that her book is called
small doses because it seems like people
can only handle her in small doses see
what I did
[Music]
you're like your I've never seen you
like that no I've never really seen you
like that cuz I'm confused why you
confused why are you confused like my
whole moral stance I'm like it might be
looking at the way the world the wrong
way like every time my mom said don't
lie I was like me your mom is not Noble
yeah you better watch what you say
it's not me it's Amanda okay yeah you
better say it's not you it's my mom's
had no blister of them all yes yes you
know that Blu Cantrell song yeah what's
the difference between me and you it was
a remix if you were a good DJ back then
you will mix both of them together
what's the difference between me in you